Traducteur: Camille Lachenal
Relecteur: eric vautier
J'aimerais vous faire partager quelque
chose que je fais tout seul, intimement,
puisque là, il y a beaucoup d'émotions
et je suis très heureux
d'être ici, avec vous.
J'aimerais me connecter avec ce que
je suis réellement, avec le cœur,
car l'enjeu, c'est le cœur.
On le sait tous.
Trente secondes, en mettant
mon attention à l'intérieur
pour me connecter à moi
et vous parler avec le cœur.
Pourquoi porter un autre regard
sur soi et sur le monde ?
J'ai compris que,
si je voulais changer le monde,
il fallait tout d'abord
que je commence par moi.
Comment j'y suis parvenu ?
Je vais vous parler de mon chemin de vie
et ce que ça m'a apporté.
Les esprits doués pour l'abstrait
ou les disciplines cognitives
se sentent tout à fait à l'aise
dans la structure de l'enseignement
pratiqué en France.
Et vous ?
Pourquoi et comment
avez-vous vécu votre scolarité ?
Personnellement, je n'ai
pas compris le sens.
Cette façon de transmettre le savoir
et l'adéquation entre cet acquis
et le sens de la vie.
À l'époque, je ne le savais pas,
mais il me fallait des choses
plus concrètes, physiques
reliées à la vie de tous les jours.
Passionné par le sport, je m'engage
dans la voie Sports Études.
C'est de cette façon que j'ai pratiqué
pendant 7 années le foot
puis le judo.
Ce fut des entrainements
rigoureux et engagés.
Jusqu'au jour où, à cause d'une mauvaise
formation de mon dos,
je dois arrêter le sport.
Ce fut un choc,
comme si tout l'univers
s'écroulait autour de moi.
Tout était remis en cause
comme si tout d'un coup,
la lumière s'éteignait.
Je vis cette interdiction
comme une injustice
et mon caractère,
que je sais anticonformiste,
devient alors révolté et rebelle.
Le corps enseignant choisit
pour moi la filière du bâtiment.
Je refuse.
Je ne suis pas d'accord.
Et comme par instinct,
je choisis la filière bois.
Là, je découvre ce matériau vivant,
sensible,
avec des couleurs,
des odeurs,
des textures.
Je suis en harmonie avec ce matériau.
Je sens un lien.
Je me sens bien.
Cependant, je ne suis pas d'accord
avec la transformation de ce matériau.
Je produis des cadres, des fenêtres.
Je ne suis pas d'accord
sur un plan utilitaire.
Je m'interroge sur le sens.
Le symbole.
L'expression du ressenti.
Toutes ces choses qui sont complexes
à définir avec des mots.
Je quitte la formation conventionnelle,
pour me diriger à nouveau vers
une formation de sculpture.
Dans cette formation, deux événements
vont transformer ma vie.
Le premier, c'est
ma rencontre avec Jean-Noël,
un sculpteur ébéniste,
un intervenant extérieur.
Par son regard sur le monde,
il va m'enrichir.
Par son ouverture d'esprit,
Par sa bienveillance envers
l'environnement, il va m'enrichir.
Et surtout, il va me donner
confiance en moi.
Puis, il y a cette anecdote.
Lorsque je suis amené à sculpter
un masque africain baoulé,
du nom de la tribu
située en Côte d'Ivoire,
c'est de cette façon,
diffuse et intuitive,
que je comprends que
derrière ce simple objet
il y a un véritable sens,
une émotion, un souvenir, un langage
permettant de transmettre des informations
autrement que par des concepts mentaux.
En sculptant ce masque, non seulement
je me révèle, mais je me dévoile.
Mon parcours initiatique débute.
Quelques années après, je décide
de partir en Afrique Australe,
car je suis en quête de sens.
Je ressens le besoin d'aller à l'intérieur
et ce, d'une manière profonde,
d'aller à la source.
Je ressens le besoin d'aller au cœur
des forêts vierges et des tribus
et c'est ce que je fais.
Là-bas, ma vie change.
Mon regard se confronte
à une autre culture.
Une autre façon de concevoir le monde.
Je fais face, je me libère
à ce que je suis réellement.
J'ai envie d'être
ce que je suis réellement,
et non pas ce que la société
ou les autres pourraient m'imposer d'être.
Je comprends comment le regard des autres
peut nous empêcher d'être soi.
Je veux être acteur de mon histoire,
je décide de faire
ma révolution culturelle.
C'est au cœur de l'Afrique,
par l'intermédiaire de la lecture
que je découvre la poésie,
la philosophie, la psychologie
qui vont beaucoup m'inspirer.
Surtout le psychologue
Carl Gustav Jung.
En effet, à travers ses nombreux
voyages et ses réflexions,
il crée un concept clé :
la liberté des contraires
ou ce qu'il nomme aussi
le principe d'individuation.
Ce concept qui fait débat,
auquel j'adhère complètement,
repose sur le processus de création
et la distinction d'un individu.
Il se rapporte à la réalisation du soi
qui prend en compte
les éléments progressivement
conflictuels et contradictoires
qui forment la totalité psychique,
consciente et inconsciente, de l'individu.
Ce concept, pour moi, résonne énormément,
comme une énergie à l'intérieur
qui s'éveille.
Je sens que le changement est vital,
je comprends que le changement
se passe par l'intérieur.
Mon processus d'intériorisation continue.
Après cinq années en Afrique,
je décide de rentrer en France
afin de faire une formation forestière
pour à nouveau repartir
avec cette expertise.
Mais le passé me rattrape.
Suite à un bilan médical,
je suis refusé pour les mêmes raisons
qui m'ont obligé à arrêter le sport.
Je suis à nouveau confronté à un refus,
à une injustice de ne pas pouvoir faire
ce que j'ai envie de faire.
Résigné - j'ai horreur de ce mot -
mais optimiste,
je décide de rester en France et
de repartir en Afrique un peu plus tard.
À cette période, je fais
une rencontre déterminante.
Une occasion d'investir un bâtiment
se présente à moi.
Je saisis cette opportunité,
je décide donc de rester en France,
en ouvrant une activité.
Là je commence à travailler avec
des objets, des œuvres.
Et je m'interroge.
Je ressens un lien entre certains
de ces objets, certaines de ces œuvres,
et ma recherche intérieure
vers un autre regard.
Je sens que c'est là.
Et pour répondre à mes interrogations,
j'actualise mon savoir
en réalisant une formation
d'histoire de l'art,
en parallèle de mon activité.
Enfin, je découvre et comprends
le langage de ces objets.
C'est ce qui va me donner le désir
de présenter ces œuvres différentes
puis de produire ces œuvres
afin d'éduquer et d'initier
l'éveil d'un autre regard.
J'ai besoin de moyens et la vie
me les apporte sous différentes formes.
Voici un de ces objets.
Comment trouvez-vous cet objet ?
Quel regard lui portez-vous ?
Quelle est son utilité ?
Comme vous le voyez, c'est exactement
la proportion représentative
d'un témoin de relais de course.
Il est en ébène,
il est doré à la feuille d'or,
en son cœur se cache une cavité
où on peut mettre des éléments intimes
à conserver ou à transmettre.
C'est un objet symboliquement fort.
Il a quitté le terrain des enjeux sportifs
pour se réintroduire seulement
dans la transmission.
Il a effacé son esprit de conquête
pour se placer sur une dimension
unique de partage.
C'est un objet qui devient particulier,
on lui attribue des vertus, un pouvoir,
comme un porte-bonheur,
une amulette.
C'est un objet apotropaïque.
Pour produire ces objets,
ceci est un exemple,
je choisis des plasticiens, des designers,
des architectes, des graphistes,
ainsi que des savoir-faire :
tourneur sur bois, brodeuse, doreur,
en leur demandant de produire
des objets avec deux idées principales :
que ces objets contemporains
puissent intégrer une symbolique
au même titre qu'un objet
tribal ou religieux.
Il s'agit de questionner
une possible valeur d'usage
en relation ou en conflit avec la forme,
tout en gardant une référence
personnelle : une amulette,
ou collective : un totem.
La divine proportion
appelée encore le nombre d'or
ou le code secret.
Cette formule mathématique
datant de l'antiquité qui régit les arts.
Elle détermine la proportion d'une forme.
On la retrouve dans l'ADN humain,
le développement des plantes,
le système solaire.
Elle représente l'harmonie,
l'équilibre entre les hommes et la nature.
C'est ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est ce pourquoi je produis des œuvres.
L'art doit nous élever,
l'art doit produire du symbole,
l'art doit participer au changement,
nous faire prendre conscience
d'un autre regard
afin d'unir les hommes et la nature.
William Blake qui a réalisé
la première œuvre, qui est celle-ci,
nous dit : « Le monde de l'imaginaire
est le monde de l'éternité. »
Je suis le rapport que j'établis
avec ce que je vois
et je change quand ce que je vois
prend une autre face.
Ces objets ont transformé
mon regard sur moi-même.
J'ai compris qu'être différent,
c'est être soi,
sincère, authentique.
L'échec fait partie de la réussite.
Je remercie la vie.
Cette transformation a modifié
mon regard sur le monde,
je crois en une réalité en dehors
de l'espace et du temps,
je crois en une énergie omniprésente.
C'est ce que cet objet représente
et matérialise pour moi.
La réalisation du soi,
comme l'aboutissement de l'évolution.
Ce n'est pas une finalité,
c'est un passage vers un autre regard
sur soi et sur le monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)